[Music]
yeah so i recently re-watched avengers
age of ultron because of a memory of
ultron saying
that when everything settles god throws
a stone at the earth this got me
thinking what if ultron who can access
all the world's database and for a
period of time had access to the mind
stone wanted to actually turn the entire
world into beings of metal and shared
consciousness with himself to not
protect the earth from thanos or an
outside force but from something that's
within the earth and cannot be undone by
any force necessary what if ultron was
trying to prevent a celestial emergence
we have collected all the quotes uh
spoken by ultron and this makes up a
good argument for this theory so um
subscribe if you haven't already and now
let's get to it
okay so hear me out so yeah what if
ultron designed by tony stark with the
help of bruce banner and based on loki's
scepter which was later revealed to be
housing the mind stone what if this
sentient ai artificial intelligence read
all of humanity's history and also the
earth and came to a conclusion that
something is deeply wrong with the
planet and that there is something
brewing inside of it which would only
serve as the doom of not just
organic creatures but the death of
himself as well if it was ever to be
born
so let's analyze his quotes and try to
make sense in the viewpoint that we now
know about celestial emergence from the
eternals as you know everything in the
mcu is connected early events are often
shaped by future events as well
like when ultron was holding loki's
scepter and revealing what's inside
which is the mind stone he said
typical of humans they scratch the
surface and never think
to look within
that hits deep when you think about the
planet as a whole humans have lived for
thousands of years and even with the
eternals being there they had no clue
about the imminent danger that's within
the core yes i'm talking about the
growing celestial data steer with that
was going to emerge from the planet in a
few years from the age of ultron events
ultron might have known about him due to
the mind stone and this would have
definitely set up his mission to wipe
the slate clean and prevent the
emergence even though human life will
die out
what would remain would be metal and a
unified collective intelligence that
might not be sufficient or even
compatible for the celestial seat to
feed on since it needs intelligence to
mature
ultron doesn't really know the
difference between destroying the world
and saving it he was born from a mission
of tony stark to protect the world but
found out that humans are the actual
danger to life on earth this would also
be true when you think about humans as
livestock for the celestial inside the
planet tumut is constantly feeding off
of human sentience and with a certain
amount he will emerge and there's
nothing on the world that would be able
to stop it well except for the eternals
apparently but ultron didn't know about
the future events that killed tiamut in
his mind he was the only one that can
prevent it he also said
the human race will have every
opportunity to improve
and if they don't
that's noah
so there's another line that really hits
the mark with this theory
there are more than a dozen extinction
level events before even the dinosaurs
got theirs
which could mean that these predators
were wiped out from the planet by
deviants in order to prevent these
creatures from feeding on humans and
therefore making the emergence
impossible since there would be no sense
in life so yeah when the earth starts to
settle
god throws a stone at it and believe me
he's winding up this one right here got
me thinking as we know now the gods of
the mcu are the celestials they are the
ones that create the stars and the
planets for life to flourish and in
return new celestial would come out from
such worlds so when the earth sells
which means as humanity is thriving in
the billions god throws a stone he is
winding up
or also the celestial will emerge and
that's why humans have to evolve into a
collective conscience that might prevent
the birth of a celestial or at least
surviving the emergence
during the fight or confrontation with
the avengers ultron stated these words
you want to protect the world but you
don't want it to change
how is humanity saved if it's not
allowed to
evolve
well it harms down on the same point
that humanity has to change in order to
survive the coming apocalypse of the
entire planet or at least prevent such a
catastrophe yes of course he might have
meant it in another way that wars and
destroying nature and all that blah blah
was in fact a dark thing about humanity
but the technological advances and
colonizing other worlds was also a
possibility in order to escape such a
fate a doom caused by their own actions
it's not like the end of the world was
coming in a few years due to this
so ultron's haze has something else
driving it
lastly the one scene that seals the deal
is the conversation between vision and
ultron towards the end of age of ultron
just before vision kills off the last
bot
vision said humans are odd they think
order and chaos are something opposites
and try to control what won't be but
there's grace in their failings i think
you missed that this part by itself
doesn't really give meaning to the
theory i have presented right now but
what follows do the fact that both
vision and ultron agreed on an
existential threat to humanity
[Music]
yes
but a thing isn't beautiful because it
lasts it's a privilege to be among them
you're unbearably naive
the fact that vision himself agreed that
humans are doomed means that he also
knew something ominous was on the way
just like ultron the milestone reveals
things
many things but not fully even in civil
war vision told wanda that he doesn't
really understand the infinity stone in
the trailer of the multiverse let's go
on to that wanderer told strange that
vision had had theories about the
multiverse but they were still just
theories vision even with the mind stone
might not know everything but there are
hints at what might be so that's my take
on ultron and the theory of him trying
to prevent a celestial emergence
so do you disagree all you want it is
just a theory discuss down there in the
comments if you liked and try to be
polite as much as you can though i don't
think that's possible but yeah
so i hope you have enjoyed watching this
video
and with that we come to the end of it
so do hit that like button for support
and subscribe as well to be a part of
the mind cue family but most of all
smash that bell icon for regular updates
on new videos right here on this channel
till the next one take care fam